one of the guys I used to read a lot in
this space has passed away many years
ago Larry Burkett used to say that'll
take you about as long to get out of
your messes it took you to get into it
how long it take you to make the mess
thank you about that long to get out of
it here's the thing I don't find that to
quite be true huge respect for Larry
Burkett it usually takes you about half
as long to get out as it does to get in
the prerequisite of that statement
though is that you get freaking intense
you lose your mind and your broke
friends think you've joined a cult
because you were dialed in baby and you
don't care what broke people think about
your financial plan if broke people are
making fun of your financial plan it
means you are on track think about it
like fat people making fun of your diet
okay think about it it's like dumb
people making fun of your education
think about it so you you don't you know
you're right on track you're right on
track then so your intensity so if if it
you know you you spent the last ten
years making a huge mess it might take
you five to get out most people are how
to die using this system not counting
their house in under three years but the
system entails this unbelievable focused
intensity and the more focused you are
and the more intense you are the deeper
you sacrifice and the less you care
about what other people think the faster
you get out the math is created by the
intensity of your engagement in this
idea of getting out of debt that's the
thing so when you say well we just want
to made up our own version of your plan
which would make it your plan not mine
ish we did Dave Ramsey ish I'm gonna get
t-shirts planted with issues all over
them yeah you can issue your way in them
getting nothing done so here's the thing
go wide open man what's the worst case
scenario you pay off a whole bunch of
debt and you hate it
go back and dad that's your worst-case
scenario